negotiations on the trade and services
agreement or teaser have been ongoing
since 2013 with 23 members of the World
Trade Organization including Europe but
is teaser the next big thing that
consumers need to be aware of after the
controversial TTIP maybe it's the first
betting service industries today makes
almost about 70% of the VSP of the
European Union as a question as do I
want to make profit or do I want to
serve public interest
the EU is already the largest exporter
of services globally a trade agreement
on services would allow further
liberalisation across markets and give
the EU even greater access to foreign
markets and allow you businesses to be
treated the same as domestic
counterparts but should there be red
lines especially over public services
Culture Social Security water for
instance in order to preserve elements
which we do not want to bring into
competition another problem the lack of
a dispute resolution mechanism under the
service agreement negotiations are
expected to be concluded in 2016 it will
then be up to Member States to decide
which services they wish to exclude from
a territory